the film States the National Geographic
family yeah third two states that
Stonehenge was in fact built 4,500 years
ago and it was a much larger site than
we thought I don't think you at home
have a place where you do experiments do
you you probably go home you've got a
sofa and a chair and a fish yes but you
don't have a workbench and you don't do
this experiment I've got various things
that I use and this really is the
decoder bench I call it because that
really is what gets to the essence of
stone Ange
this is called sonic vibratory research
you're not hearing the Overtown are you
know you're not a musician I know no not
really
now if you can move just a bit wrong
this is a potato thank you you think
it's a potato you eat it no it makes us
out yes does it say what it's a language
that needs to be decoded but basically
you actually heard that from the potato
I just did so right so you have heard a
noise similar but very similar yeah no
you don't do it well enough yet you need
some time in the lab yeah you're a
beginner I and we always make the
mistake of just doing some stupid sound
it's not that no it's you you're the
kind of guy he looks at dolphin and say
stupid fish no I feel sorry for you well
that's very kind of you I mean generally
anyway